[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody happy Friday I'm John
Luke once again joined by Ben it's your
boys back at it again that's right and
today we are playing predator hunting
grounds which just came out it is
available on ps4 and what what is it a
bit of a game story okay it's Friday
it's been a heck of a thing so yeah
we're gonna play some today check it out
and if you want to play with us
we're definitely down for it we still
will figure out how we're gonna do that
I'm playing on the PC by the way it has
cross play I'm not 100% sure how I could
invite people to a party around ps4
we'll see let's figure it out together
there's got to be a way to do it cuz I'm
looking at the private mansion lobby
right now and it has an indicator oh it
does that but then here's the thing I or
the friends list and it's only given me
my epic so let's just try I think for
now while while we get warmed up let's
you don't don't take that invite I
accidentally clicked your name thinking
I could do something
heck yeah join my party I accept this
game invite have you fired happy Friday
to you Brandon nice to see you alright
let's hop in here let's see if we if
we're able to get in as it says right
here long queue times which I try to
play a little bit with Jake and Matt the
other day last night when it fit came
out and we were not able to get in at
all so the this morning I got in and the
queue times were down to like 20 or 30
seconds 400 second to whatever at I ran
minutes
no no no it it went pretty quick so I'm
curious if it's still going that way not
the 20 it's a 30 second range
oh no there you go 30 seconds so when
you talk about how have a pink keyboard
and mouse on my keyboard
girlfriends keyboard you would be able
to see its way over there also I wish I
had that pink keyboard mine's just a
boring black one yeah mine's kind of
lame too
all right so you'll have to forgive me
since I wasn't able to get in yesterday
I haven't had a chance to play yet so
I'm kind of gonna be learning a little
bit this as we go I did some of the
tutorial with the predator
I will undoubtably forget the buttons
they're a little clunky on PC but we'll
see how it goes it's it's all good also
look we're all we're matching up with
just PlayStation people again cool I
haven't played with any other PC people
you're the first PC person I've seen in
this game I need to adjust the volume
even more this man is talking into my
ear oh I turned all that off the people
in the chat won't be able to hear that
cuz I'm you the bat [ __ ]
oh I mean like the the game guy no
that's what I'm saying I muted that oh
that's all that's a good call so maybe
maybe you just tell me what they're
saying I know you're supposed to
communicate with your team I'm just
turning it all down right now
all right okay well this is actually
running better than it was before this
is this is already kind of uh okay a
difference all right all right so you
just gotta kind of like move up to these
objectives and hope that we don't get
murdered by NPCs or the predator so are
we like salata equivalent of the like
the squad in the original predator but
it's like taken out I believe so guys
half the characters are played by
funhouse people really yeah like half
the funhouse people did voice work for
the scheme apparently that's weird so
I'm really looking forward to hearing
Bruce green or at least Williams like
randomly yell while we're doing stuff
yeah I see a sniper down there got him
nice but yeah these NPCs pop up and
they're a heck of a thing to deal with
by a heck of a thing I mean you just
kind of shoot them and then they die
okay they're too serious already get
them all I can probably adjust my game
to be a little less free me I feel like
if I have a good opportunity I'll lower
setting so that's not I was saying
earlier too I think there might just be
some optimization stuff still going on
with this cuz I really shouldn't be
having the tackle problems I'm having
mm-hmm
but it'd definitely be worth maybe
messing with something and seeing what
could get adjusted kill the maintenance
officer and do that I see more bad guys
I keep forgetting that I took appart to
have better okay oh yeah you can you can
do one-hit kills from behind a perk to
do better hipfiring so I should do that
more often all right also I like the
predator hasn't jumped us yet and it's
yeah how quickly is that supposed to
happen typically it could happen any
time Oh No
so that's a yes we're just waiting
feeling I stole the plan cool we're
gonna overload the station substation
yeah
I'm on that I'll cover you here good
conversation about Pizza happening right
now I saw that lets promotion alert uh I
turned off the motion blur but the
motion blur is pretty aggressive I could
uh I could I couldn't reduce the motion
blur th-that's actually that was the
last thing I did before I was like oh
shoot this runs a lot Chris maybe maybe
do that for sure okay hold on I'll try
and find a good spot for that
traffic's please
well those persons getting mud on him
motion blur turn that off
it's a little better frames still kind
of a little frame me but yeah the motion
that does help it just oh I'm not too
time killer I'm getting the goop on me
dude the goop yeah the goop
I got 16 xp for rubbing blood all over
me oh we got a a predator sighting
happening up here well like we saw a guy
who got killed by the predator I think
he just popped up and then they ran away
cuz I've seen with just a predator also
try and kill the same NPCs were killing
so I think they can their whole thing is
just messing with people oh there they
are they just jumped off the top of the
building oh there is he was walking so
casually I was like that can't be him
dude was strolling what was that alien
blood I'm gonna put some goop on me as
well yeah do it goop dude I got goop
points I'm just talking about puck is
this PC yeah we're playing on PC but
it's cross play with yes board yeah I
think we're playing right now yeah oh
wow
we could track him down and kill him I
think unless he's just sitting up there
yeah whoa
you just like not trying to sleep this
from a tree I do behind you yes down
I heard the cloak and all those those
cool sound effects happening we should
probably get to our objective right
that's what I would think but it seems
like our people want to get a murder on
that's fair
oh he's really close to me and I don't
like it
guys come on objectives see I'm gonna
here's the thing I'm gonna run off and
go do the objective and I'm gonna get
murdered they're gonna get murdered
oh it's happening I do see him do a
thing so if you press you'll you'll like
point out a thing I'll do it I think if
you get it on him it'll actually pull
them out call him out properly
please come on ps4 right now yeah heck
yeah our C and D people are both on
PlayStation and the predator is also on
PlayStation but if anyone else has this
we should try to get like some private
games going or something yeah if anyone
knows how to invite people on ps4 from
PC let us know cuz I'm not really sure
how to do that I didn't I couldn't
really find anything
who got him side the search area I'm
gonna find that radar computer
hello honey realize this game was like
straight-up published by Sony though is
it well it has the Sony interactive
entertainment logo I got the beginning
oh dang so at least I had it since um
what part published by Sony
OOP heard the sound article oh yeah this
looks like a computer yeah I should come
support you rebooting this computer
cover me oh he's here it in inside real
close oh yeah he's bleeding there
it's the laser beams on piece above us
yeah I see my say my fam I see my family
oh he's down oh he's going top yeah
inside the glass trees always gonna blow
up
oh god move run run run run run I'm down
below
I shouldn't be I shouldn't get got okay
okay he's just giggling I'm safe I'm
safe oh wow it was a big blast radius
dude I guess so I was like ah from
behind a wall or something I should I'm
not fine yeah we did it alright that was
a good opening match I like that was
good I haven't seen anyone kill though
the predator he is yeah that's that's
exciting
I'm the one who got the kill at least I
pick Eliot I'll shoot at him when he
went down I can't believe I didn't make
it out though like a fool you're gonna
watch Clone Wars see us heck yeah go
enjoy Clone Wars does that new season
out thank you I've been keeping up your
I may have died and not made it out but
your boy definitely got that XP all
right let's uh it feels good to shoot
stuff yeah yeah I'm gonna adjust my
settings all of in-between to see if I
can get some higher frames going sounds
good I'm going to open this field Locker
and see what I get we should also be
doing that
let's see graphics if I just turn
post-processing quality and shadows to
live it's like hi instead of epic
okay what if I just bump everything down
one that might help a little bit let's
see if that makes it a little bit nicer
it might that might that might help uh
let's check the field Locker what did I
what I get some sweet lube Doc's been
died a hero
indeed there's only one way to go and
that's being a hero
oh no the the the price of freedom is
steep
I finished Crisis Core and I'm still
crying oh okay gun scan I just wanted to
be hero camo shader okay I do like that
the main menu is just my two characters
like going at it you know so what are
you rocking assault rifle yes all trifle
and should have access to the the
minigun but I guess I don't
so I've got a shotgun yeah I should I
should switch to shotgun I do like the
shotgun it's very powerful
and I got a share for it did I get a
predator customization thing blue
shotgun there we go about the assault
rifle what can i what can I do with this
thing green sure that sounds fun
no laser died yet I'll probably get that
after the next one yeah that comes
pretty quick
oh I should have some perks - oh
actually hero increase hipfire increase
experience from all sources oh
definitely that one yeah yeah it's a
real good one crease overall health yeah
it seems like good ones to do Brennan
asked did you guys have fun playing the
Friday the 13th game yeah I did and I'm
real busted up that it's yeah me too
it's kind of dead and I really liked it
yeah I was I was looking forward to that
Jason X update they promised at one
point I should probably put perks up my
my predator branch master cow okay
um differed lens alright you wanna start
but neither one oh yeah I'm down cool
just keep it keep it rolling I guess I
should have that on me in case somebody
wants to hop in hello one sec well it's
loading um I'm gonna go grab my phone
entertainment again
will do how's game online good actually
it we're worried because yesterday we
couldn't get into any matches right away
but seems to be kind of going alright
today play crysis core on PSP or
emulator PSP yeah you know me sure play
crysis core is this on Steam or epic
games epic games and PSN mm-hmm that's
correct and it's it's also cross play
heard of Daymare I have a Daymare was
originally supposed to be a resident
evil 2 fan remake until Capcom decided
they were making a Resident Evil 2
remake and told them to stop so they
took what they'd worked on and actually
change it over in a Daymare and it's
actually got some of the voice actors
from Resident Evil in it
Oh weird look there they were like going
for it going for it wow that's cool
our female predators a real thing seems
kind of weird looking at it I don't know
predator enough to say if it exists or
not
but they are looking kind of thick
though both the male and female
predators when you crouch in a tree with
them they're behind just sticks way out
I mean I imagine for you know species
reproductive purposes a female predator
would exist in some fashion as far as
whether they've existed previously uh I
don't know I haven't seen much of the
recent movies
I know there's a lot like I think
there's a really long running like
predator comic or something could not
tell yeah this looks like it's already
running better after I knocked
everything down but the textures are
also taking a while to wake up not
potato mode no this is this this is the
the real experience everyone check out
GameSpot after dark it's true Brandon
made a good call if you are checking out
after dark you're missing out you guys
had a pretty cool episode this week
where you guys kind of just talked about
what you've been doing you talked about
playing guitar hero again mm-hmm oh yeah
yeah me my girlfriend and playing guitar
hero did you listen to it then I didn't
get a chance to yet but I only know cuz
I published the video publish the video
but I'm excited to give it a listen
later this week probably well I'm
grinding some stuff fountains if ya the
ultimate podcast game
I'm gonna go grab these these parts oh
it's our other guy afk it's possible
he's moving now he's on PC oh heck yeah
more PC boys what isn't this it's not
potato mo this is this is the real deal
but I wonder it's better on PC or ps4 I
think it comes down to what you prefer I
like having the option to play both on a
controller and also with a mouse and
keyboard especially an FPS that's the
thing is uh in a world where cross play
is possible I no longer have to choose
based on where your friends are my
friends are which is like really nice
it's like normally I get called duty on
ps4 cuz that's where my friends are but
it was like this time I was like I can
get on PC cuz I could just play with
them anyway yeah yeah let's go roley's
tracker bugs everywhere I gotta get
remote on me well someone just got
stabbed all right I got mud on me now
no no sign of the predator yet there are
other biding the time where's Arnie
that's a good question
I couldn't get him for this one I do
like though however when you are going
to do the objective to bring someone
back from being dead the symbol to let
you know where it is is the like hands
coming together okay that's pretty good
so that's that's real good on the nose
referential that I definitely got it's
like just subtle enough that I I I dig
it
yeah right Oh heard that's how I serious
use open the tree what
I see him
I love this because I think one of my
favorite scenes in the original predator
is uh when Jesse the body Ventura just
takes that minigun and just like mows
down like half the jungle
heck yeah it's like us all shooting
wildly at the trees and the branches
coming off like that shit's pretty good
you know someone was like oh the tree
branches have got to fly absolutely I'm
glad they did
okay do we know where he is well we got
regular dudes on our asses though got
one of them but if I just tossed like a
flash grenade out for the sake of it oh
he's up there we got it nope still doing
its thing oh my god he is just jumping
watch the branches oh the subtitles
broke for me and they're extremely small
I can actually hear these voices alright
can you hear them yeah weird I'm not
actually hearing what people talk that's
strange you see the do you see the the
subtitles maybe I took me I turned some
setting down in the volume volume down
this in the settings it's entirely
possible I'm just looking up at the sky
thinking about this predator coming down
I feel like we also this looks standoffs
a few close to each other because that
just leads to I thought that was the
predator turns out it was just the pigs
sable alarm what oh geez ya blew up yeah
well I hear him
oh right in front of me oh my god
there's a Terry option what yeah you can
parry him it's kind of great
oh god I'm getting shot at okay
they timed that they feel like they knew
oh good that I dropped ammo scheme
literally makes you feel like predators
like predator but with gun about him I
found him I found him I found coming
there's a big armored boy what if I just
whoop flash-grenade there he is yeah we
can get out of here yeah why don't we
just leave they ran the opposite way I'm
gonna get that mud all over me again
so dey still back there
come on did God do this man
construction zone exit hang him ping him
all the time it's my favorite thing
Sonny can't get away it's not possible I
have a question when you a match make is
it possible to specify you want to be
the predator or is it random yeah you
could say pick one okay okay so maybe
we'll do half the stream where we're
playing together and then we'll we'll
switch over and I'll play the predator I
like it
howling that you can't like throw your
party in and be like ah one of us might
end up being the predator yeah I mean
that leads to just I guess like cheating
though right yeah I guess what's the fun
in that though I don't know it's always
missions real quick yeah this mission is
real quick I think my characters Elise
Williams actually oh yeah
yeah there's a guy made it
I'm not gonna die this time you're gonna
live damn it where's the predator I
don't see him the helicopter is then we
got to get to that chopper
I can't get my character to say get to
the chopper or even though the button
says get to the job
all right what about do I press hold the
ear F off someone took my line yeah I
made it I didn't die that time oh right
- it's true I'm all about pinging your
boy played a ton of Battlefield back in
the day and that's my thing
buy this for $40 or wait for a sale
artists you've heard to save yet I I
mean this is my first time playing it so
I see if what you see right now looks
like enough for you to enjoy
you probably be good otherwise if you've
got like an interest but you want to
wait and see what the add to it it's
always good to wait sure it's a good
thing about asymmetrical games like this
is there isn't too much of an ask if you
get like these five friends to hang out
and play it and you've got enough people
for a game right still have my
Quarantine beard you bet I do okay it
just keeps growing out and getting more
and more Haggard yo what oh you know
yeah I had voiceover volume all the way
down cuz I can I'm confused it with a
voice chat volume I just got uh I just
got a whole bunch of really cool outfits
shoot got a bunch of outfits yeah I got
like chrome armor for my predator
but when you when you sign in does it or
when you hit quick match does it let you
choose it all or is it just take you
right away I do a quick match it just
takes me right away okay I have five
sunglasses now so that's cool helliya
sunglasses all right got some optics
oh so I can't use all these outfits
because they're not for the character
that I chose all I could be a recon now
never mind I found it okay
it's a I haven't been getting any
predator upgrades well I did get a field
blocker this is where I get
it's aliens in this game Oh wouldn't
that be like a cool twist if they just
put an alien in this game but they
didn't tell anyone I'd be here that
would never happen my big they would
have to advertise it just cuz of like
the licensing around it but that'd be
cool all right I did get a predatory
skin and without the helmet on okay uh
let me know when you're ready I'm good I
think we're already looking the army no
not yet
well it says we're researching for me
though no or now its sister Esther yeah
that's just like I think that you're
seeing like the little loading bar next
to the party member I think that's just
it's saying hey you got room for more
people gotcha hi Wayne how's it goin
good to see ya
hope you're having a wonderful house the
service so far actually better friend
and I thought it would be I mean you
were saying we weren't able to get in
right when it launched yesterday last
night and then Ben you were saying you
had a little bit of issues in the
morning but they seem to be ironed out
we're getting in a matches pretty quick
now
yes it's it's fallen pretty well
it should boy on recon live in my best
solid snake life yo what happened to my
ping and why is it twelve or sixteen I'm
probably hosting that's what's happening
my Enderman says uh for me it's a
bouncing between like eight and twelve
now that I can't you hear their voices
talking yeah it's it's kind of loud
how far in the tutorial for the predator
did you get I think I did the whole
tutorial how about the fact they call
running in the trees pred core I missed
that oh wow yeah good like that's like
like a Dutch a TM trademark and we are
pred core pred core oh my god that's
pretty good I like that yeah you can
tell I'm sneaky cuz I have tassels
hanging off of my ouch
alright let's do this man ready
[Music]
see I kind of wish that managing
equipment might be a little bit more
easy to do then cycling with xenyx but I
was sure it works
I could probably mess with the keys
how's this game I heard it's not what
everyone thought it was it's an
asymmetrical multiplayer game and I
think that's what they were saying it
was from from the beginning maybe people
got excited we're like ah finally a
predator like story game or something
they've had that concrete there is
concrete jungle back on the gift yeah
right okay finally like a like a current
no sure plug these things in man
sure it's bed I don't know if it's bad I
mean it's not having revolutionising I'm
having fun yeah maybe a good time I
don't know if this is like you know how
many how much legs this game has but for
now I'm having a fun time with it I feel
like this is gonna be a like a good plan
do more with as it goes on I hope so I
mean that's how I also felt about a
afraid of their Dean yeah more loot
you get that all I heard some zapping
I hear I hear him I have not heard him
oh I heard that some of the the lines
are just very good also I love that a
line for throwing of flash grenade is
eyes open just loops is this on easy
mode so the thing is like the SOB he's
in the room which room he's in the room
with ninja gamer I marked him
oh no ninja gamers dead he's definitely
good this is not good but there is no
like difficulty right like it not that I
could see no the difficulty I think is
supposed to come in the predator
predator messing with you yeah because
they I are pretty pretty easy to take
down that's they're not too tough
they're kind of meant to margins be
nuisances in the way right yeah so he's
growling
Joey's I don't like it I don't like
their he's um no I heard him oh yeah I
heard that too sons being sneaky yeah
what is this cars driving by outside I
could hear that Gary what's going on
here I'm gonna use this great launcher I
[Music]
see him he's over there
I had them a little bit as soon as he
saw me she got the other buddy can we go
buy them yeah should we try and do that
he's he's in the opposite direction of
the objective though I say we do it
alright yo oh he's up in the trees over
that way
okay I'm gonna try and go for our buddy
right behind you so most probably kills
you is that it you're out no so there's
we're doing it right now but you get
kind of put into this this unit where
you have to wait he's right behind us
he's shooting at me so you have to wait
like 30 seconds and then your teammates
can revive you it's pretty out of the
way though at least in this instance
ma'am we gotta get her pal ninja gamer
back
also I'd I know that they're there like
watching exactly where but they
definitely are I hate it it's ah it's
unsettling listen we call them in they
come back he's gonna come back no I hear
him I see some leaves in the trees seem
laser targeting me yo our dudes back go
so see oh oh he's up there there you
serious
so I got a lot of hits off on him
I still see him if someone got those
good shots I saw those blood splatters
all the way back all my ammo is out Oh
No so that's that's the thing you get
excited about shooting the predator and
then you lose all your ammo oh how do I
get more ammo
you're watching jean-luc play right now
there are ammo boxes or from the NPCs
okay well we should probably go to that
objective now but we we tell some damage
to him yeah does he heal I imagine not
they may have a gear that heals them so
this got a like retreat and put that
down I guess I actually got a good call
get the mud on yeah oh is that mean he
can't see with his predator vision or
whatever I believe so
also he definitely had his laser sight
on me she was training a deep has a lot
of issues on consoles right now I looked
into it yeah are you shooting at me
Toki would I love just how loud the
cloaking stuff yeah that's good I'm glad
they did that I'm gonna get on that car
I like how we're still trying to do our
objective like if you weren't trying to
do this and then an alien attack you you
wouldn't just completely abandon
whatever it is you were trying to do oh
that man's head exploded
got c4 there ah when you hear the scream
that's when you know he's healing that's
the giveaway that's the toughest and I
love it okay now I gotta go this way oh
I could really use some ammo a little
mail I don't know that I just realized
I'm very far away may you really do get
like a lot more xp for like headshots
and stuff and you do just normal kills I
here I'm here I'm see his laser - he's
somewhere over here whoa he just dropped
down oh there is yeah throw it away
mo please
yeah mo would probably be nice oh there
he is
it's up there hi Sam
you got down I'm gonna heal really quick
all right oh he's in the he's in the
plants oh you want up in the tree yeah
just get this this is probably the the
most experienced failure I think yeah oh
yeah he's pretty good oh yes oh he's
right behind you whoa his aprender lead
foot steps like that I just never really
thought about it
cuz they like shake the screen hmm I
probably keep going to the chopper right
that's fun despite problems I'm having a
good time playing it me too I think if
if you can get like a group of friends
together to just oh shoot he's here uh
to just run through it and do it you
probably have a really good time let's
not that's the one thing I think we're
missing right now is just having more
people to play with mm-hmm totally
randoms are cool and all but don't blow
your buddies yeah yeah that's how I felt
bugging it's like dead by daylight and
and uh who's right behind us Friday 13th
it's like most fun when you're playing
with your buddies and you're having all
your all into discord and you're kind of
laughing and having a good time
murdering yes it's a real Robocop kind
of step when he steps Oh God he's right
there
oh he's down for a bullet in its head
just get that get that predator blood
all over my oh we got him we'd like
straight-up like kill them Kelvin you
didn't even get to do the detonate yeah
a bunch of bad guys okay now we have to
like keep the body
Oh interesting that's kind of neat
there's like malt there's multiple wind
states even as a so like we killed them
but now we have to get extra point then
keep that body together that's cool I
like that
all right yeah we gotta we gotta protect
the body let me pick up the body like
what do we do
no I think we have to just wait out the
timer on it oh okay
well I got the heavy-duty guys coming in
there we go we go next be damned
oh it's in it and it's only else cuz
someone ran away before they they went
in the chopper I think they didn't
realize like oh like a different wind
condition can you sell turnips in this
game yes I would assume so
that's a Predators favorite pastime I
think predator bodies go for a really
high amount of bells with Anoka really
dude
tops home looks looking for him Timmy
Tommy hey they escaped they did now cuz
I wasn't gonna do it too and then you
you you told me not to Oh Brandi got
River City girls heck yeah oh yeah dude
heck yeah let's go again
those are really fun video to just kind
of see cool let's do what I got more as
humans and then we'll all do a predator
run all right a mobile ten now ah dang
dude more of that also got four filled
lockers open
all the red digital camo and some ski
goggles got messed me up
whichever Lots cross-play it is
cross-play and the 30 minute or 30
second wait isn't even that bad yeah
although somebody was saying they were
having some longer times on ps4 it's no
good okay swap out some guns here I'm
gonna try this our rifle
weapons in here modify changed my site
up now
can't put a suppressor on here yet
though or get a bigger magazine but
that's fine sister Meili damaged well
put on some face paint
I'd be using this this minigun if it
actually had it
I guess I'll switch to recon because
that's probably better for having a
sniper any cool Predator stuff he was
gonna be a microtransaction yeah I feel
like they've got a setup where they
they're not counting on it
switching over to it but I'm never gonna
say no someone will always find a way
I'd probably buy a cool hat now - why
aren't you saying they're all the
weapons as the predator I can't pick
there's a lot of options there's like a
bow yeah you get the bow later on disc
smart disc apparently does like the
Jever play Dark Sector I was about to
say is it just which was just the the
glaive from crawl yeah okay just that
kind of kind of deal let's do one more
man you down then we'll all try predator
can you cover yourself in might've
become invisible to the predator yes you
told me yeah we're we're getting all
muddy a little bit earlier
when's the review coming that's a good
question
I think eventually soon i I'm not
unfortunately I'm not up on on review
stuff oh man why is the support class at
level 35 that's the one I'd play
wouldn't ya wants a review coming I
don't know but I know there is one I
think
it'll take at least a little bit of time
just because you know it's a multiplayer
game so it's not really something you
can play early yeah
looks like I could steal quick yeah so
I'm kind of hoping they eventually show
like a road map
oh let's let's deploy at the weed farm
all right do you know why you know
that's where we gotta go I hope you
reveal like a road map where they talk
about adding a bunch of stuff right but
I'm wondering how much more predator
stuff they can put in before they have
to go and like cross over territory sure
if they added an alien updating we're
like what did they just add an alien
update where instead of fighting marks
knew you were fighting feeling I like it
also that's a good call Oscar I'm very
excited for future age 4 it's like next
week here or not next week it's really
soon though put a lot of stuff into that
video game so the lux Edition worth it I
don't even remember what is in the
deluxe edition you got no idea oh look
you got the tassels now - let's see what
we got going on ice oh I had to get the
eye patch as soon as I saw it I'm gonna
mark the mud cuz I'm gonna put on the
mud mmm
it's prime mud over here dirty arty
would be proud
here we go okay let's do yeah like some
urban nook would be really cool urban
map would be cool a sci-fi map would be
cool
Oh what if they did a UH vp1 and they
set in and like the snow that pyramid
there you go we kind of need our yeah
get Adrian Brody in this game I'm
already tired of running straight box
you're gonna get that on our last class
I pitch yeah he's like behind us is up
in the tree
oh hello yikes you did no I I shot the
guy we were supposed to kill like a
whole bunch and then I ran out of ammo
and then I just pulled out a shotgun and
setup point-blank oh my uh my subtitles
are doing that thing to do super tiny
our pal just got got our other pal just
got gone oh well this is gonna stop
moving oh he's coming down oh no I was
right there
he was almost up I don't see him I can't
mark him for you well Chango
damn that's quick so I guess she's gotta
be like brutal yeah he's gotta like get
into it mess him up
no XP I got a little bit of XP yeah damn
alright well that's probably a good time
to swap over to the predator yeah right
I was too excited about my eye patch
that I just got a serial blind I
couldn't tell where they were I gotcha
I'll leave your party cuz I think that's
how that has to work again unless unless
someone wants to someone else hasn't
lost my screen so Ben can watch from his
home yo I just unlocked the Elder sword
for for my my predator that guy dude
alright uh quick play so I'm doing quick
play you should pop up a choice to go
for predator it might take a bit longer
than okay it's not giving me an option
it just said Matt it's just matchmaking
should I should have happened before
after uh go for a quick play it
shouldn't Oh
because I still had a party billing
that's why there we go I see I see
predator that's the that's the ticket
okay
well we'll just a chill here for a
second heck yeah I'm gonna move my my
discord over so I can see what you're
doing so I can still see the chat and I
can mess with my loadouts make myself
look really good
also I have to ask there are people in
year who are definitely like it bigger
predator fans than I am are Brent locks
like the actual thing that they're
called like I just I'm just I need to
know and maybe I'm making fun of pred
core and pred cores like an actual thing
- oh God
I took off my character's mask my
Predators mask and is I ain't been
prepared to the customize I still so how
much in the way predator customization
can the humans get the predator killer
suit I haven't seen anything how much
how did I get my mask off there
apparently there's an option to do it
yeah when you may pick your skin color
it shows it off but I don't know how to
like remove the mask straight up yeah I
want to be oh I guess cuz we're moving
the mask is a mechanic so maybe you can
Oh interesting they're gonna be review I
think there is pretty sure yeah so I
told I told you great facts I was
talking about it earlier both these both
of these predators looking looking real
thick though they're just just doing
their thing
whoa all right maybe I could get custom
thing going here trying to get a custom
match going I'll just miss my loadout I
did not like the submachine gun did not
have enough ammo no I think it's a it's
a salt salt rifle and shotgun are very
good yeah well I was trying the rifle I
I didn't get tried enough to actually
see if I really like it or not but I
felt like that paired with the or the
sniper rifle I paired with the machine
gun woulda been a good dude good choice
please do that do you have access to the
minigun because I know pre-orders are
supposed to get it no no it says level
68 awesome missed opportunity there I
was gonna say
dang still waiting everyone wants to be
the predator
ba da da da da da
oh I'm kind of not surprised that not a
lot of people don't have this yet
because it was kind of a surprise it
surprised me I didn't realize it was
coming I had no idea yeah I mentioned
that at work like a predator he's coming
out this week and I was like what yeah
oh yeah that game oh you can't you can't
buy these trophies so I wonder if you
have to actually go kill them and
grid-like get them it's kind of weird
cool
oh boy
jeez still waiting yeah that's what do
you see the estimate is one minute and
approaching five that was a lie
we'll give it a couple more minutes but
Alan just sit here on our way on a
loading screen so maybe we'll just go
back to playing as the the the Marines
yeah see maybe I should change my mask
all the masks are so expensive I feels
like probably but the top tier the
customization right yeah
well I'll see if I can I can quick match
into a predator game oh wow it's just
three minutes now barely promoted this
game at all release little details on
the game
yeah it's true what's for lunch today
for a chili mmm I haven't eaten yet but
maybe I'll treat myself to something
nice for dinner we'll get like a like a
pizza I haven't had a pizza yet this
week why can't the nocturne Rask that's
cool
doctor and profits rad plagues cool
I'm wondering if there again I'm not a
big predator fan but I'm wondering how
like someone's probably oh shoot this is
exactly the predator mask I wanted oh
you just got it did it it happened I'm
gonna die immediately no you're gonna be
fine everything I've seen so far evolve
looks to be better than this evolved was
had some more time and they put some
more stuff into it I still think the
best comparison is Frankie heck Friday
13th is is a bit better
I'm not big up on on the other one
that's everyone still plays what's
called they had a bunch of yeah Depp by
daylight I wish that game had different
objectives than just messing with
generators yeah I've hooked up with it
and so the big issue I had with it is I
would only ever play with my friends
like we were talking about earlier
because that's most fun but then you
don't earn XP when you're playing
private matches with friends so none of
us were ever gaining any experience
which means none of us was able to get
the cool store like unlock any of the
perks or the cool like alternate things
so I think in private matches now they
just give you everything I think they
changed that yeah I think they've
changed that sense but back when I when
I did play it they did not and it was
very much like okay this is weird cuz we
can't really like engage with all of
that there is in the game but also we
want to play with each other yeah what
if I put forth that the best
asymmetrical multiplayer game is
actually Resident Evil resistance
yeah man you seem pretty up on that game
I do like it I don't know if it's just
because it's got that little bit of
Resident Evil flavouring in it but
everything works and it's it's got a lot
of variety it's got a good amount of
maps
they're adding characters and stuff
they've already got a roadmap set out
for it so I know what's coming up
someone I know who doesn't speak very
well English wise calling the game Derby
daylight
derby delight sounds like a wonderful
time that's pretty good
Derby delight sounds like a minigame
that be in tower unite man uh real weird
how the game makes you wait a lot of
time just to hop into this other screen
that I'm also now waiting on how about
if it hasn't like frozen or anything
right no no no it's not frozen it's just
like you think I should quit out and try
again but I wait any longer know that
because it counts down like there isn't
like a ready check or anything no there
is yeah I've hit ready but I mean they
don't have it ready it counts down
eventually and shows you in yeah like I
don't have any it doesn't show any of
the other people it still says waiting I
don't know if that means like they're
there and I'm waiting for them or I'm I
think you might be waiting for the
people to show up that's it took you
just to a different screen to continue
waiting oh god what should we do what do
you thank you uh yeah maybe back out and
retry one more time I can't find
anything we'll just we'll go back to
what works let's try one more time
I would like to be predator and if not
yeah I can understand if people don't
like resin evil I don't think it was
terrible though what 3 now the oh maybe
maybe 3 they're talking about but
resistance was alright 3 was alright
yeah I think they're both alright yeah
don't like 3 nearly as much as I like to
personally
but I dig I dig I dig it people like
three and that's cool yeah it's not bad
game by any means had a good time
playing it unless you're saying just
Resident Evil is bad which case was good
that's that's wrong yeah unless you're
saying Resident Evil the movie was bad I
might hear out an argument for it but
you know grey fox is a John Lee who kill
only six feet from a distance apart and
all that all right
makes sense yeah yeah keep safe yeah she
was way too short
yeah threes always been short though I
guess I felt more prepared for that than
anything else I wasn't too man might
make sure with that game has doesn't
have anything to do with the length I
think I was more did my I was really
just kind of let down by nemesis I wish
there was more of him in that game yeah
it's it's weird how they took the really
cool way that the mr. X works in two and
didn't really like what they do it fruit
I think the open I think the opening of
the game is the best part like that
downtown area when he's chasing you in
that that part's great yeah also it
feels like it lost kind of what the
original had where it felt like he could
pop out at any moment even though it was
all scripted totally so like yeah like
like at the beginning it feels that way
and then it it loses it because I think
part of it is because he own after that
opening in the downtown he only ever
shows up in like a cutscene and like a
Vickery obvious like this is clearly a
scripted sequence moment yeah Escobar
oh boy alright Ben what do you think
should we should we call it and switch
over yeah I'm down for whatever you feel
like I want to keep playing me not
particularly if you want to show off
what playing predators like you could do
a quick round of the tutorial people
want to look up predator they can they
can look up other stuff I'm sure we'll
have plenty of gameplay up on gamespot
comm you do it is this game spot go
check it out let's get you back in here
man yeah oh god where's my where's my
social stuff it where'd it go there we
go
boom zap game invite get in here let's
do it
you know as much [ __ ] as I give them I
actually kind of enjoyed some of the
Resident Evil movies oh good they're
good like dumb fun to just watch they're
not like em yeah one is got some good
moments in it good moments that they
stole for a Resident Evil 4 yes and then
not choose bad 3 fries kind of cool
because they basically were like what if
Mad Max but with zombies yeah yeah and
that was kind of good and then uh oh no
they get real bad after that like they
just become so bad yeah I like the the
CGI ones just because the house pretty
oh the CGI recipe for movies are the
dynasty Warriors of video games oh yeah
I watched one of them I think the first
one those are also canon i believe yeah
you should watch
I think it's degenerate we I think I've
talked about this on stream before I
think it's degeneration is that the
first one no it's it's later on I think
but it's the one with Leon and Chris and
they do like a weird gun kind of thing
in like a hallway with like 80 zombies
and then there's all it's just they rip
they straight up like ripped off John
wick like he's like like Leon's doing
like John wick moves is that the one
kind of I don't know if it's a ripoff as
much as its
just them like doing dumb I think was I
don't know I had Leon in it the one I
saw had leave in it did it have the
minute and a half long discussion about
how breaking beds the best series ever I
don't recall that cuz that's that's the
best part of the one I'm talking about
besides the gun kata stuff is where
they're flying to where they're supposed
to go and they just break out into like
Breaking Bad was great television let me
tell you that's weird
it's it's a lot Resident Evil CGI movies
okay I'm gonna I'm in the mood for some
trashy video game CGI movies I've
watched Advent Children for the first
time so you know I'm ready for anything
I think it was degeneration i watch cuz
that's the first one okay maybe I got my
titles mixed up I don't know him very
well
you know I actually enjoyed parts of
Advent Children though looking back at
it still trying to get over the the
dilly dally shilly shally bit
there's the generation damnation and
Vendetta
so maybe damnation is the one you're
thinking of maybe his degeneration was
2008 so that have been yeah that's not
enough time for them to hype up Breaking
Bad no definitely not look at re
showdown like Castlevania that'd be
fantastic
there Castlevania is so good you know
what they are doing though that is gonna
be made by the people made Castlevania
is that duffel May Cry series yeah right
excited fat and uber I'm even getting in
this match
don't replaced or being placed it's
happening hey is happening it is
damnation where we're getting
confirmation okay cool alright that's
that's good because I wanted to go back
and watch it again because it's been a
while probably should have a Resident
Evil viewing party oh we should let's
just tell the movie night tonight should
just be Resident Evil damnation and then
everyone else hates that except for me
or like super exactly it'll be great oh
the Starship Troopers CG movie I haven't
I'm gonna go to the wheat farm I haven't
watched it but I've heard about it I do
pick you just click on it yeah everyone
went to the weed farm it's all coming
together
my secret plans why'd you want to be
separated I feel like that's no good I
don't think it's where you drop but it's
a vote to see where everyone drops jump
I'm into how my character looks I'm
feeling this
someone left their phone off the hook in
that helicopter all right let's do this
I'm ready
first things first oh I hope this is mud
[Laughter]
I'm absolutely ready to get wrecked just
like the last game oh oh oh yeah man
that was rough
I'm gonna follow you you're see now not
a B I was be there mix the mixing it up
stick close to this wall here I hear
Sally case yeah I realize that in this
game marking targets probably isn't a
good call mm-hmm
because everyone's gonna assume that
it's the predator and literally anything
all we need to just keep going we
shouldn't even bother with these guys
yeah
I'm behind you your tassel squad go you
know it oh shoot
you good you good the boys they saw me
the boys they're dead now our guys are
still back in that it's town though oh
oh dude predators on you
the Predators here oh we're here guys is
the minigun perfect excellent what is he
shooting at though I don't know
you okay dude okay the predator was
definitely still here I'm pretty sure he
was trying to look at me yeah this guy
is just shooting hey you guys gotta do
the thing okay I didn't want to like
abandon him but he was kind of just
shooting at the wall yeah he's just okay
she's just you guys are just [ __ ]
around then boom spaceships taking off
here oh this is the spot we got messed
up last time one of them got down that's
the one that was just shooting off into
nothing oh I forgot this isn't just
Batman this is ssgss back oh wow but
Batman I didn't know I needed I love it
your headshots are brutal in this game
oh yeah they just explode
yikes yikes is right out here I'm steel
these hard drives
the shooting doesn't feel too bad when
you scan why actually digging it
[Music]
flip adore - that's that's the team
we're just seemed door - oh I hear him
clicking out their hard drive need two
more - I got them all
wait can I pull this finally heard him
plot a sword
I think destroy the computers not that
computer that computer no oh oh dude is
here all that dialogue yeah let's go get
our pal do we should we get them button
up whoa bad boys
Eric ouch you're gonna do
I have to shoot all the stuff yeah it's
all the computers I got you break the
computers stop all the downloading
stop all the downloading
[Music]
this guy
I think either dude just do it up left
yeah that's fair do this thing we got
out whoa
got the impact for the headshots - yeah
it's real good dope
he's over there I need more ammo medical
supplies where are these keys oh there
they are
I'm stupid he's right outside oh he's
right there where some walk past the
doorway yeah I see him
what's up dude
Oh No
stop him stop oh my gosh Oh roofline run
run run run run he can really tear you
up
look my sacrifice was the heroic
sacrifice we needed to get the murder on
that predator god speed then have fun
guys I'll never forget you I hope you
don't forget me as trying to one more
I'm in
I do like the the end end of the round
thing reads helicopters hovering over a
giant massive crater so I wonder how
that happens versus the other one where
we have like the perfect specimen thing
yeah like I wonder if they I think
there's a button that you can press for
it if you press it in time oh so so the
other one didn't press it in time this
one did yeah it's a good point gray fox
shooting uh if the monitors is how you
break the computers they're there max
that are all like self-contained I guess
do dodo dodo all right let's try over
tap yeah yeah
I would switch back to the asana if I I
think I I like the the rifle but that's
that's the way to go for me new face
all right I do have a new assault rifle
at I let me check
oh man I don't know it's for you but it
is hot right now uh yes I was gonna say
I'm it's real warm in the bay today I'm
actually really kind of stoked that we
decided to go without cameras for the
sake of having more of them shut up
because your boy is not dressed for
success right now is dressed for comfort
Johnny can't be a good sign he's not
getting enough air inside your body I'd
love to do the Gabe that's just me well
see now you're yawning it's gonna make
real I care if you soon will the chats
gonna yawn this is how it works
someone's gonna be a sympathetic as I am
white everything blow up so there's like
a button that the predator can press if
they had taken out two just I guess set
off a bomb to try and get everyone else
it's weird though because as long as you
know what's happening it's pretty easy
to escape it yeah you say that but the
first thing that happened I got blown up
like a fool well I'm saying if you know
what happens like if you know what's
going on it's pretty easy
almost like I don't know you're inside
like a like an indoor environment where
like it's a little more labyrinthian and
harder to navigate but yeah there's
gotta be something for the most part
it's just a you just kind of run away
and then you're you're fine the insane
gesture is gonna be our predator
I wonder where these people are all the
Bret the predator left great well
the printer was fed up with waiting oh
they left we're about at the end of the
screen so what if we don't get any more
people by the time it hits absurdity we
call it I'd say take take it out and
then bring it back in because I'm
wondering if it's a on the for most
people have realized oh well I've
realized if people aren't in the match
they'll never put them in oh that's
probably haven't the predator thing I
saw the wait like seven minutes just for
the like to even get to that screen
though yeah which is why it makes me
think that the predator who was in our
match was like oh shoot it didn't pull
in two people I'm gonna be here forever
maybe cuz Oh first day server stuff it's
a thing yeah that's a bummer cuz we're
actually having really good luck at the
beginning
hands pillow
okay we got a third one yep oh yeah yeah
there we go let's do it there's no weed
farm here seemed easy to escape big
warning on the screen yeah I get the
first time I didn't realize how big the
explosion was gonna be an ant realize it
was gonna end the round so I was like ah
he's on the roof
I can stay inside the building that'll
be fine there's a wall between me and
him yeah I was wrong I've only done one
round as the predator but we haven't on
the stream yet yeah we tried to but it
was taking so long we were just having
no luck that we decided to move on
because we we don't want to sit here the
whole stream yo test the squad let's go
I've got my my flippin AG I'm ready to
go to town what I didn't get me okay
I switched back to assault rifle but it
didn't give me any my my [ __ ] on it all
so I'm watching all of you just put on
just really funny it's the way it goes
these people are professionals they know
what they're doing anyway yeah I didn't
realize by switching back to my assault
rifle I to re-equip all of my my like
attachments it's no good that's kind of
annoying so I don't have my my laser dot
oh well I just picked a whole new gun so
I have to earn the stuff for it again
eric says he's gonna hold off buying
this game thanks guys yeah man no
problem that's we're here sir we're here
to show it off and let you figure out if
you think this is worth your time
these guys are marking dudes oh I
thought we were gonna be sneaky about it
never mind
whoops sorry that's my bad we're good
this game doesn't really seem like it's
built for stealth like it has stealth
elements but yeah I'm gonna cover myself
in this blood and here you go blood we
run over to the waterfall really quick
if anything kills me it's gonna be this
you put taxes on while playing as the
predator not that I've seen I think the
predator is Tacitus unfortunate oh my
god it was a lot that guy exploded give
me a gun what I get I want that oh oh I
just hear the predator sound yeah that
may hurt all of us breathing at the same
time Oh God Oh Oh God
cover mean where's the try and shoot me
through the window sneaky see him oh
he's right there he's right outside of
this building
oh the AI also shoot him - that's nice
oh my gamers decided to like stop
working for a half a second ow I'm also
getting a bunch of snack messages so
that's what's going on with that
[Music]
and somewhere levels on reminds me cold
night I could see it like the forest
level hope there is yeah what if one of
these in this community Friday's we just
play Goldeneye source whoa that sounds
pretty good
it's it's Goldeneye but in the source
engine that's pretty good I don't want
to get cut up I'm not here for it
[Music]
I'm very ready to leave this area me too
we cool we can let's do it yeah yeah
yeah oh he's up in the trees
oh yeah I wanna I wanna get some we can
get more people and on because I feel
like everyone's able to play Goldeneye
source yeah right
cuz I feel like we've done we've got
some community Friday's going on we
don't have too many people were able to
join yeah some weird one too because I
don't even know how to invite like
people for crossfire yeah but I mean I
guess watching in a way is also UD hey
that's that's true every stream is a
community stream exactly no I just heard
on oh that was not a person
well he's behind us Tereus he's
invisible that's fair but for real
though the dialogue is the best gotta
run thanks for the stream guys if you
have a oh you got a tude hope you have a
good weekend as well thanks for hanging
out thank you gray fox
oh he's behind everyone you're that
ninja there it is
lucky there should be the same kind of
hose work in the area we can follow the
truck search inside area inside search
area yes you're still gonna get there or
you're you're there
shoot we gotta find a tanker found it
okay I'm not going the right way I got
it
now they're not eating lunch thing is
starting to catch up to me yeah man I
always try to eat lunch before the
stream because it's like it's no good
yeah hey I don't recommend skipping
meals it's not great a hand that was
just yeah that's a hand rolling Wow
games pretty okay
[Music]
these dirty my water I think somewhere
around here's her to Zack
we can keep going though she's right
here no my body top dang it
Oh me as a trophy wait
you saved me nobody's hitting the button
pick me up so my gosh we can make it we
can make it we can make it we can make
it keep going
Oh God so just huge so close oh we're so
close oh damn I was so close
I appreciate you picking me up oh that
was cool that was a fun way to end now
one guy got out though cuz he just ran
it's true which means we won that was
fun that was cool anyway yeah that's
been that has been taught to say alien
alien predator now that has been a
predator hunting grounds I dig it I like
it I'm also I think the big question is
sort of like how much legs is it gonna
have like you know how much am I gonna
play before I get kind of bored of it
I'm very curious if they're gonna add
more to the roadmap but I'm surprised
how much I actually like just dig
playing it yeah it's a good song nobody
fix the the load times its launch date
though so you know I'm not too yeah it's
gonna be some server issues and you
cross play and all that I will say it
already has the step-up of a Friday the
13th and that's not buggy yeah it's and
it's going pretty good it is finished
yeah it does have at least a good level
of polish about it
from what we see anyway yeah so anyway
guys thanks for watching thanks for
watching this community Fridays if you
like this stream this is your first time
checking it out hit subscribe because we
do streams every weekday at 2 p.m.
purges usually the one out doing stuff
me and Ben do stuff on Fridays
any other dates me to fill in and now a
Dave in the UK has started streaming
during the UK times so if you're
somebody who uses a week during that you
can check that out so it also varies it
just might start streaming too we might
get Australia it's doing - you know
there's always someone in the chat every
once in a while saying hey where's Jess
well you don't worry she'll start
shooting just keep your eyes peeled so
that's pretty exciting so yeah stay
tuned for that we'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]